on vous a piégé les chroniqueurs avec un
assistant ragots qui travaillent avec
nous qu'on adhère et on adore qu'elle a
mon chéri et vous allez voir la vanne
est toute simple mais c'est un bon
délire
regardez il n'aime pas être au top 10
des filles
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
comment son string et notamment quatre
visions d'horreur et j'aurais aimé plus
à lire et le pape une fessiers
l'hôtellerie son drake son string aussi
qui me fuit d'un verger sur le couple et
le petit france je ne crois que c'est
normal que tu sens très bien
[Musique]
tu pourras lui donna tartt ça lui va
très très bien s'en douter des très
jolies fesses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais dis moi tu as un string toi c'est
normal
[Rires]
un monde
m
si je chantais pas
cela
[Applaudissements]
le
[Musique]
c'est quoi c'est quoi l'enjeu
si j'ai mon île au fond du coeur font
pas mais on parie
[Rires]
[Musique]
plus c'est facile
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que je me suis même
[Musique]
les remercie adèle jean transitoire
avant la dernière manche eric gavoty
risque gros bisous
même trop celui-là merci mon chéri
stefan petit cadeau mais assure qu'il
peut l'ouvrir ici mon chéri matthew chew
voyage et ouvre le toit vous la toile en
toile donc à dos et aux cadets il a été
super empêtré m'enerve aix en othe
pendant qu'il ouvrait son jumeau
regarder juste la tête de maxime kenny
la tête de maxime delespaul s'il vous
plaît regarder
[Rires]
bon ben laden c'est ton cadeau mon chéri
regarde des gars que je t'ai offert
c'est pour toi mon chéri la polo faire
at il dit oui bien sûr tu peux l'ofac et
limogés rivasi
merci passé pour toi qui lis moi et
merci mon attelle d'amour même
[Applaudissements]